y ustedes y yo estamos jugando un juego
para ver quién lanza más rápido una
pelota lo que necesitamos es una pelota
más o menos así y un cronómetro que haré
mi mejor esfuerzo por dibujarlo
con un cronómetro
para marcar el tiempo que la pelota pase
en el aire entonces lo que hacemos es
que cuando uno lanza la pelota hacia
arriba el otro va a tomar el tiempo que
dura la pelota en el aire y vamos a usar
ese tiempo para calcular la rapidez con
la que se lanzó la pelota hacia arriba
vamos a asumir aquí y en los siguientes
vídeos sobre movimiento de proyectiles
que no tenemos resistencia al aire que
es la resistencia del aire o la
resistencia del aire
resistencia
al aire
es nula es decir casi no hay no existe
resistencia al aire
y bueno
entonces vamos a ver el tiempo que dure
la pelota en el aire pues va a ser el
tiempo que le tome a la pelota a subir
desde que la lanzamos hasta caer y si
recordamos de nuestro vídeo anterior
esta es la gráfica del desplazamiento de
la pelota entonces lo que va a ser si no
tenemos resistencia al aire es que en el
periodo de tiempo que le dura aunque me
dura la pelota en el aire la mitad de
ese periodo de tiempo
es lo que le va a llevar a la pelota a
subir y llegar hasta el punto máximo
detenerse antes de volver a bajar
así que el tiempo
vamos a escribirlo aquí
el tiempo
que le toma la pelota a subir va a ser
igual al tiempo
que le toma a la pelota bajas
entonces
bueno vamos a imaginar o vamos a tener
ya unos imaginaron los números más
concretos vamos a decir que nuestra
pelota
este duro en el aire
y el cambio en el tiempo de la pelota
fue igual a 5 segundos cómo voy a
calcular la rapidez con la que lance la
pelota bueno con esto de que el tiempo
hacia arriba es igual al tiempo hacia
abajo que tarden más en viajar en bajar
perdón vamos a ver que el cambio del
tiempo
hacia arriba o el tiempo que duró la
pelota subiendo es igual a la mitad de
este periodo que va a ser
2.5 segundos
y durante este tiempo estos 2.5 segundos
fuimos de una velocidad
inicial no sé cuál fue mi velocidad
inicial una velocidad inicial
pero lo que sí sé es que llego a una
velocidad final d
00 metros sobre segundo subió la pelota
llegó hasta su altura máxima y aquí se
detiene queda estacionar en el momento y
empieza a descender por eso es que la
velocidad final en este periodo de
tiempo que es la mitad del tiempo total
que estuvo la pelota en el aire la
velocidad final es cero por esta razón
entonces también conocemos que la
aceleración de la gravedad
sobre la superficie de la tierra la
aceleración de la gravedad es igual a
menos
9.8 metros sobre segundo y aquí les
recuerdo este - me está indicando la
dirección de este vector aceleración
nuestra convención era que todas las
cantidades
o los vectores cuya dirección es hacia
arriba se iban a representar con
cantidades positivas y los vectores que
fueran en dirección hacia abajo se
representaría su dirección con un
símbolo negativo como la aceleración de
la gravedad va hacia abajo por eso es
que ponemos este - para indicar su
dirección y también tenemos o conocemos
otra fórmula sabemos que el cambio en el
velocidad de la velocidad
es igual a nuestra velocidad final
menos nuestra velocidad inicial
voy a cambiar otro color para que se
note un poco la diferencia entre cada
uno de sus términos el cambio en
velocidad
es la diferencia entre más nuestra
velocidad final y nuestra velocidad
inicial
entonces
tengo aquí que bueno sé que mi velocidad
final está es igual a cero
entonces aquí lo que tengo es que mi
cambio en la velocidad
es igual a menos
mi velocidad inicial
y de la fórmula de la aceleración que
hemos visto en vídeos anteriores sabemos
que el cambio voy a ponerlo en el color
el cambio en la velocidad
base de igual
la aceleración de la gravedad que en
este caso la aceleración gravitatoria es
d
- 9.8 y puse metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado porque esa aceleración metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado
multiplicado por el cambio en el tiempo
por el cambio en el tiempo y aquí el
cambio en el tiempo
se trata de el cambio del tiempo para
subir para llegar a mi velocidad final
de cero entonces es este valor
de
2.5 segundos
este segundo se cancela con uno de los
segundos de aquí y me el resultado del
cambio de velocidad
vamos a usar nuestra poderosa
calculadora
y vamos a usar a multiplicar
este
92 puntos 19.8 punto 8 por 2 puntos 5
y nos quedan menos
24.5
-
24.5 metros sobre segundo esa es la
velocidad inicial ya que tenemos que en
nuestro cambio de velocidad es igual a
menos mi velocidad inicial si esta es mi
cambio de velocidad entonces
mi velocidad inicial
es igual
menos
me cambio de velocidad que es igual a
menos menos
24.5 metros sobre segundo menos por
menos de más entonces mi velocidad
inicial es igual a
24.5 metros sobre segundo esta es la
velocidad con la que lancé la pelota
para que pudiera mantenerse todo este
tiempo en el aire
entonces así eres simples que pudimos
calcular la velocidad inicial el tiempo
total lo dividimos entre 2 y lo
multiplicamos para hacer los cálculos y
así obtenemos la velocidad inicial y así
es como hemos calculado la primera parte
de este problema
otra parte que me interesa saber es cuál
fue el desplazamiento o la distancia que
recorrió esta pelota este durante el
tiempo que estuvo en el aire quiero
saber el desplazamiento la altura hasta
qué distancia llegó hacia arriba la
pelota cuando la lance a esta velocidad
entonces ahora vamos a trabajar con la
fórmula del desplazamiento la fórmula
del desplazamiento nos dice que es este
desplazamiento es igual a la velocidad
promedio
velocidad promedio
multiplicado por la diferencia en el
tiempo
una forma de calcular la velocidad
promedio
siempre que tengamos sí y sólo si
tenemos una aceleración constante y aquí
como estamos trabajando con la
aceleración de la gravedad terrestre es
una aceleración constante nunca cambia
entonces bueno puedo usar esta velocidad
promedio como esta fórmula la velocidad
final
más la velocidad inicial
todo esto dividido
entre 2
entonces bueno ponemos tengo mi
velocidad final mi velocidad final sé
que es un
es un cero ya tengo mi velocidad inicial
que es de
24.5 entonces mi velocidad promedio es
igual a
24.5 entre 2
y esto resulta ser
12.25
metros sobre segundo es mi velocidad
promedio entonces ya tengo este dato
para calcular
la distancia o perdón el desplazamiento
porque estamos hablando de vectores es
igual a mi velocidad promedio
12.25
metros
sobre segundo
multiplicado por el espacio de tiempo
como estamos viendo
hasta el momento que el aparato llegó a
su altura máxima recordamos que este
periodo de tiempo es la mitad del tiempo
total entonces está del tate es igual
2.5 segundos estos segundos se anulan y
el resultado del desplazamiento
12.25
x
2.5 este es igual a
30.625
metros de desplazamiento esto es la
altura que alcanzó la pelota que es algo
pues bastante impresionante creo que
bueno no sé si existe alguna persona que
pueda lanzar una pelota a esta altura es
más o menos la altura de un edificio de
nueve pisos y espero que hayan
encontrado divertido este vídeo y a lo
mejor pueden ustedes jugarlo alguna vez
para entretenerse en una tarde de ocio